it's great to be joined today by aneroid
krishna who's the edgar thompson
professor of public policy at duke
university he's been studying and
investigating not only how people become
poor but also how they escape poverty so
maybe let's start with the entry into
poverty first and then talk about the
escape later in your studies
what sort of categories are there for
the circumstances that push people into
poverty to begin with
hi David thanks for having me on the
show pleasure let me let me start first
by backtracking on your question just a
little bit because the question of
people falling into poverty is a very
recent one but 15 years ago
people stopped being captivated by the
policy question of how do we move people
out of poverty that's still a very
important question but they started
asking the parallel question of how do
people come to be poor in the first
place
are they all born poor seems unlikely if
not how many weren't born poor but fell
into poverty and if that's a large
number then shouldn't we be doing
something to prevent the creation of
poverty to prevent people falling into
poverty even before we step in to offer
assistance to move people out and when
they started researching this question
then my colleagues and I found that
between 1/3 to 1/2 of all presently poor
people were not born poor they have
fallen into poverty within their
lifetimes a number of reasons account
for people falling into poverty but the
single most important reason across the
majority of countries is bad health and
high health care costs now when it comes
to health care different countries have
very different systems in terms of
health care and of course this is the
subject of much political debate
does the type of health care system a
country has impact the likelihood of one
falling into poverty as a result of
health expenses actually no David I mean
what really matters is whether you have
a health care system that can be called
the health care system whether it's
financed through taxes whether it's
financed through legal bindings on
employers whether it's financed through
personal contributions that doesn't
matter what really matters is how many
people have access to this system easily
and how many people have a safety net
under them that they're not going to
lose the shirt on their back if someone
in their family falls seriously ill or
has an accident aside from the issue of
health expenses do you see a difference
between developed and developing
countries in terms of what causes people
to fall into poverty in the first place
so even within rich and poor countries
there are differences there are some
countries where the rate of falling into
poverty is very low and these are the
countries that have robust health care
protection for their citizens that's
rich countries like the Scandinavians or
Canada but also poor countries like
Colombia and Costa Rica but if you were
to look at the reasons for falling into
poverty that need to be guarded against
health care is number one that that's
without question everywhere I mean the
only countries that have single-digit
poverty rates are countries that have
what I called robust healthcare
protection systems but other reasons for
falling into poverty job loss our
studies in North Carolina showed that a
lot of people had lost their jobs during
the period we were doing the study
because factories had run away to China
or somewhere else
and but what was really critical even in
those instances of falling into poverty
was not the job loss itself many people
lost their jobs
not everyone fell into poverty those who
did suffered an additional calamity and
that was the loss of health care
insurance followed by a calamitous
healthcare incident in the family let me
ask you this you've clearly pointed out
that only some of those who are
currently poor were born into poverty
but let me ask you a different question
which is given that one is born into
poverty how likely is it that they will
remain in poverty and if this differs
again from country to country or between
types of countries by all means I'd be
curious about that so that's that's the
flipside of what we've been talking
about and in essence an individual has
to cope with both sorts of pressures the
pressure pulling that individual down
and then the better pressure that's
lifting the individual up unfortunately
David what's been happening is that the
kinds of avenues that used to be
available for people to get better jobs
to get middle-class jobs during the time
of the Industrial Revolution
you know when lots of farm kids educated
to high school could move off the farm
and come to cities and get employed on
assembly lines which were rapidly
expanding and get a unionized job and
get you know an assurance that they're
going to be looked after till the day
they die and they needn't fear poverty
anymore those kinds of jobs are not
being produced in as many as large
numbers either in the United States and
other developed countries or even in
very poor countries the spread of
advanced technology has been a
phenomenon not just in the rich west but
all over the world wherever there are
global value chains and so the prospect
for a kid coming off the farm in Kenya
or India or Indonesia or any of this
host of largely rural developing
countries the prospects was such a kid
to come out from there and get a
middle-class job is much much
dimmer than it used to be before so
there is in some senses a crisis of
moving out of poverty even as countries
themselves are growing rapidly the
success stories the people that do move
out of poverty
what sort of either circumstances
environments or activities and decisions
does that seem to be related to it's
related of course to the individual's
personal ability to begin with and their
hard work so that goes without saying
the problem arises when there are
individuals large numbers who are smart
and word work hard and still don't make
it you know there they might make it out
of poverty but you know what would it be
like if you had an Einstein that
converted that person into a security
guard or a truck driver I mean nothing
against you already guards and truck
drivers but and Einstein should do
better than that what really matters is
the availability of a wide and easily
accessible pipeline you know what
pipeline that leads almost seamlessly
from from the time you're a primary
school student to your career sort of
cradle to career you know a nurturing
primary school environment a high school
environment in which you are exposed to
different opportunities where you have
access to role models who follow
different careers who can then show you
the ropes you know if you want to do X
then here's how you prepare for it these
are the exams you have to write this is
the additional coaching you need to
acquire this is how you become
competitive those kinds of pipelines are
a broken they're broken I mean in in in
most situations of poverty kids grow up
without access to good quality education
they grow up without access to the kinds
of role models who could show them the
paths forward you know beyond becoming
what people in their community
traditionally become to becoming
something that
new and growing economy is creating by
way of better opportunities those
pipelines need to be mended david and
there are examples from across the world
of how those more accessible and and why
pipelines have been put in place now in
terms of I mean not to I don't want to
sort of ignore the horrible reality of
being poor by the American federal
poverty line standards in the United
States but there's no doubt that there's
a difference between that and sort of
the abject poverty of living in a
developing country on under $1 a day can
you talk a little bit about how the path
out of poverty might be different when
we're talking about the group living on
less than $1 a day in the developing
world versus someone who is maybe in the
United States and might even be working
but in poverty how do those
circumstances differ in terms of the
opportunity to get out oh those
circumstances differ widely vary widely
David I mean if you look at the spread
of inequality if you look at for
instance average asset holdings and
compare them with the spread of asset
inequality across the world wealth
inequality across the world the United
States occupies the last 20% its poorest
people about as poor as the 80th
percentile or you know the fiftieth
percentile but in in in India in China
in Indonesia in Nigeria the richest
people have as much wealth as the
richest 5% in the world maybe not to
legend 0.1 percent but certainly the
richest 5% 1% but poorest people I like
poorest people in in sub-saharan Africa
so and even in sub-saharan Africa you
have countries which have this spread of
inequality in those circumstances the
struggle to rise out of relative poverty
is much much tough
because you have to go the entire
pipeline from zero to 295 in the US it's
it's it's still a struggle it's still a
struggle because of lasting prejudices
which block these pipelines because of
structural inequalities which block
these pipelines but there is a floor
below which very few people sink and
that floor is not the same as the floor
in developing countries which which
still require the bulk of the world's
assistance from from a sort of dollars
perspective it seems that $8 to the
extent that they're useful and there's
lots of controversy about what types of
aid aid money is is useful and sort of
counterproductive we can do much more in
terms of the number of people that we
lift up in places that are dealing with
more abject poverty then in developed
countries right it's merely because
you're talking about each dollar makes a
bigger difference in some of these
places yeah I mean that's the financial
calculation but there's also a moral
calculation if you were to think of the
world's people as one if you word for
what for for a minute if you were to not
think of them as belonging to different
countries but as belonging to a common
humanity then morally you would start by
making sure that no one starves or no
one is is homeless I mean you can pick
your principles and your standards but
then you'd apply the same principle and
standards across a common humanity and
that's another reason for doing exactly
what you said we've been speaking with
Annie rude Krishna he's the Edgar
Thompson professor of public policy at
Duke University and he's been working on
this issue
for the past 15 years thanks so much for
talking to us about it very important
work thank you David
pleasure